what are the different trajectories that
intelligence
when acted Upon This World Super
intelligence what are the different
trajectories for this universe with such
an intelligence in it do most of them
not include humans
I mean if you the vast majority of
randomly specified utility functions do
not have Optima with humans in them
would be the like first thing I would
point out and then the next question is
like well if you try to optimize
something you lose control of it where
in that space do you land because it's
not random but it also doesn't
necessarily have room for humans in it
I suspect that the average member of the
audience might have some questions about
even whether that's the correct Paradigm
to think about it then would
sort of want to back up a bit if we back
up to
something bigger than humans
if we look at Earth and life on Earth
and what is truly special about life on
Earth
do you think it's possible that a lot
whatever that special thing is let's
explore what that special thing could be
whatever that special thing is that
thing appears often in the objective
function why
I I know what you hope but
you know you can hope that a particular
set of winning lottery numbers come up
and it doesn't make the lottery balls
come up that way
I know you want this to be true but why
would it be true there's a line uh from
Grumpy Old Men where this guy says in a
grocery store he says you can wish in
one hand and crap in the other and see
which one fills up first there's a
science problem we are trying to predict
what happens with AI systems that you
know you try to optimize to imitate
humans and then you did some like our
lhf to them and of course you like lost
and you know like of course you didn't
get like perfect alignment because
that's not how you know
it's not what happens when you Hill
Climb towards the outer loss function
you don't get inter alignment on it
but yeah so
the I think that there's so if you don't
mind my like taking some slight control
of things and steering around to what I
think is like a good place to start
I just failed to solve the control
problem
I've lost control of this thing
alignment alignment
still alive control yeah okay sure yeah
you lost control
um but we're still aligned anyway sorry
for the matter yeah losing control isn't
as bad as you lose control to an aligned
system yes hopefully exactly you have no
idea of the horrors I will shortly at
least on this conversation
all right sorry it's actually distracted
complete what are we going to say in
terms of taking control of the
conversation
so I think that there's like a
sealant chapterus here if I'm
pronouncing those words remotely like
correctly because of course they only
ever read them and not hear them spoken
um there's
a like for some people like
the word intelligence smartness is not a
word of power to them it means chess
players who it means like the College
University Professor people aren't very
successful in life it doesn't mean like
Charisma to which my usual thing is like
Charisma is not generated in the liver
rather than the brain Charisma is also a
cognitive function
um
so if you if you like think that like
smartness doesn't sound very threatening
then super intelligence is not going to
sound very threatening either it's going
to sound like you just pull the off
switch
like it's you know like well it's super
intelligent but stuck in a computer we
pull the off switch problem solved
and the other side of it is
you have a lot of respect for the notion
of intelligence you're like well yeah
that's that's what humans have that's
the human superpower
and it sounds you know like it could be
dangerous but why would it be
are we have we as we have grown more
intelligent also grown less kind
Zees are in fact like a bit less kind
than humans and you know
can you could like argue that out but
often the sort of person has a deep
respect for intelligence is going to be
like well yes like you can't even have
kindness unless you know what that is
and so they're like
why would it do something as stupid as
making paper clips
aren't you supposing something that's
smart enough to be dangerous but also
stupid enough that it will just make
paper clips and never question that
in some cases people are like well even
if you like mispecify the objective
function won't you realize that what you
really wanted was X are you supposing
something that is like smart enough to
be dangerous but stupid enough that it
doesn't understand what the humans
really meant when they specified the
objective function
so to you our intuition about
intelligence is limited we should think
about intelligence as a much bigger
thing
well I'm saying that it's that then well
what I'm saying is like
what you think about artificial
intelligence
um depends on what you think about
intelligence so how do we think about
intelligence correctly like what
you gave one thought experiment to think
of think of a thing that's much faster
so it just gets faster and faster and
faster I think and it also is like is
made of John Von Neumann and has like
and there's lots of them because we
understand that yeah we understood like
trying to find Newman is a historical
case so you can like look up what he did
and imagine based on that and we know
like we people have like some intuition
for like if you have more humans they
can solve tougher cognitive problems
although in fact like in the game of
Kasparov versus the world which was like
Gary Kasparov on one side and
an entire horde of internet people led
by four chess Grand Masters on the other
side casparov one so like all those
people aggregated
to be smarter it was a it was a
hard-fought game it's like all those
people aggregated to be smarter than any
individual one of them but not they
didn't aggregate so well that they could
defeat Kasparov but so like humans
aggregating don't actually get in my
opinion very much smarter especially
compared to running them for longer like
the the difference between capabilities
now and a thousand years ago is a bigger
Gap than the Gap in capabilities between
10 people and one person
but
like even so pumping intuition for what
it means to augment intelligence John
Von Neumann there's millions of him he
runs at a million times the speed and
therefore can solve tougher problems
quite a lot tougher
it's very hard to have an intuition
about what that looks like especially
like you said
you know the intuition I kind of think
about
is uh it maintains the humanness
I think
I I think it's hard uh
to separate
My Hope from my objective
intuition about
what super intelligent systems look like
if one studies
evolutionary biology with a bit of math
and in particular like books from when
the field was just sort of like properly
coalescing and knowing itself like not
the modern textbooks which are just like
memorized this legible mess you can do
well on these tests but like what people
were writing as the basic paradigms of
the field were being fought out yeah in
particular like a a nice book if you've
got the time to read it is
um adaptation and natural selection
which is one of the founding books
you can find people being optimistic
about what the utterly alien
optimization process of natural
selection will produce in the way of how
it optimizes its objectives you a lot of
people arguing that like in the early
days biologists said well like organisms
will restrain their own reproduction
when resources are scarce so as not to
overfeed the system
and
this is not how natural selection works
it's about whose genes are relatively
more prevalent to the Next Generation
and
if you if like you restrained A
reproduction those genes get less
frequent in the Next Generation compared
to your con specifics
and
natural selection doesn't do that in
fact Predators over run prey populations
all the time and have crashes it's just
like a thing that happens
and many years later
uh well but people said like well but
group selection right what about groups
of organisms
and
basically the math of group selection
almost never works out in practice is
the answer there but also years later
somebody actually ran the experiment
where they took
populations of insects
and selected the whole populations to
have lower sizes you just take pop one
pop two pop three pop four look at which
has the lowest total number of them in
the Next Generation and select that one
what do you suppose happens when you
select populations of insects like that
well what happens is not that the
individuals in the population evolve to
restrain their breeding but that they
evolve to Kill The Offspring of other
organisms especially the girls
so people imagined this lovely beautiful
harmonious output of natural selection
which is these these populations
restraining their own breeding so that
groups of them would stay in harmony
with the resources available and mostly
the math never works out for that but if
you actually apply the weird strange
conditions to get group selection that
beats individual selection what you get
is female and infanticide
like if you're like reading on
restrained populations and
so that's like the sort of so this is
not a smart optimization process natural
selection is like so incredibly stupid
and simple that we can actually quantify
how stupid it is if you like read the
textbooks with the math
nonetheless this is the sort of basic
thing of you look at this alien
optimization process and there's the
thing that you
hope it will produce and you have to
learn to clear that out of your mind and
just think about the underlying Dynamics
and where it finds the maximum from its
standpoint that it's looking for rather
than how it finds that thing that leapt
into your mind as the beautiful
aesthetic solution that you hope it
finds and this is something that was has
been fought out historically as the
field of Pop of biology was coming to
terms with evolutionary biology
and uh and you can like look at them
fighting it out as they get to terms
with this very alien inhuman pot in
human optimization process and indeed
something smarter than us would be also
be much like smarter than natural
selection so it doesn't just like
automatically carry over
but there's a there's a lesson there
there's a warning
with a d natural selection
is a deeply sub-optimal process that
could be significantly improved on it
would be by an AGI system well it's kind
of stupid it like has to like run
hundreds of generations to notice that
something is working it doesn't be like
oh well I tried this in like one
organism I saw it worked now I'm going
to like duplicate that feature onto
everything immediately
has to like run for hundreds of
generations for a new mutation to rise
to fixation I wonder if there's a case
to be made in natural selection
as inefficient as it looks is actually
uh
is actually quite powerful like that
that this is extremely robust it runs
for a long time and eventually manages
to optimize things
it's weaker than gradient descent
because gradient descent also uses
information about the derivative
yeah Evolution seems to be there's not
really an objective function there's a
there's inclusive genic Fitness
is the implicit loss function of
evolution simply cannot change the loss
function doesn't change the environment
changes and therefore like what gets
optimized for in the organism changes
it's like take like gpt3 there's like
you can imagine like different versions
of gpt3 where they're all trying to
predict the next word but they're being
run on different data sets of text
and that's like natural selection
always inclusive genetic fitness but
like different environmental problems
so it's it's uh it's difficult to think
about so if we're saying that natural
selection is stupid if we're saying that
humans are stupid
it's smarter than natural selection
smarter stupider than the upper bound
do you think there's an upper Bound By
the way that's another beautiful place I
mean if you you put enough matter energy
compute into one place that will
collapse into a black hole and there's
only so much computation to do before
you run out of nagentropy in the
universe dies
um so there's an upper bound but it's
very very very far up above here like a
supernova is only finitely hot it's not
infinitely hot but it's really really
really really hot